the demo takes place in what appears to
be an outer castle town of the ashina
clan
it starts with their castle looming over
you in the distance
and it ends at a broken bridge which
forces you to descend
into the snaking ravine below also
has anyone else pointed out that there's
a guy waving and taunting us on the
other side
because that guy's gonna get it in seven
months time the ashina are
definitely under assault here walls are
crumbling
temporary defenses are up there's even a
giant
inexplicable crater in this area where
you fight the yoga
and as you read a little bit about all
the terrible creatures that are showing
up here
you almost start to feel a little bit
sorry for the ashina
because to make matters worse they've
got an unkillable shinobi on the loose
and
it turns out he's pretty op so let's go
over why
most of my discoveries were of new
animations and attacks
since sakiro offers more button
combinations and
more mid animation attacks than ever
before
for example l3 while running offers you
a slide
you can now kick jump off of enemies
you can jump off of walls you can do
almost anything in mid-air that you
could do on the ground
and even your standard r1 that's usually
a 2 attack combo is now
a 5 attack combo and you can hold down
r1 at any point in your five attack
combo
to charge up your next attack in that
sequence
and there's one more thing i know about
there's even a new
cross slash attack which is performed by
holding down
l1 to block and r1 to attack at the same
time
and i don't know about you but that
reminds me of dark souls 3's weapon arts
where you hold down l2 and r1 to attack
so while the cross slash attack is a
neat attack
it's not like it really has that much
utility so
i would not be surprised if they plan on
allowing you to switch out
this cross-slash attack for different
attacks
just like a different weapon art and i
think this because they have said
that unlockable skills will be one way
that you're able to make your character
feel
more unique and this l1r1 combo
is a really good candidate for that in
my opinion
so let's talk customization in my
interview with robert simpson
robert conkey and yasuhiro katau
yasuhiro clarified that
while there might not be the traditional
rpg elements that we're used to
like leveling up and stats he did
confirm
that there will be unlockable skills and
upgrades
that are going to make your character
feel more powerful that's exciting
so right now we do actually already have
a few
unlockable skills that have been
confirmed there's one called
makiti which is a counter that you
perform by dashing
into your opponent's thrust attack there
is
this second sword on your back which i
asked about which
they said would be eventually unlocked
for use although they didn't say exactly
how and
they mentioned that it's going to be
possible to upgrade the grappling hook
in some way and lastly they have
confirmed that
new prosthetic weapons and also upgrades
to your prosthetic weapons
would be unlockable as well so obviously
one of the biggest criticisms that's
been levelled at sikiro
is the supposed lack of customization
and
while it seems likely that saqiro will
never get a change of clothes in his
adventure
at least we're going to be able to sort
of tweak our character with unique
attacks and
upgrades so hopefully that's enough
especially
if we can sort of spec into different
attacks
like that cross slash i mentioned i'm
really excited to unlock
more prosthetic weapons as you know
these activate with r2
but they can combo with r1 as well so
for example the flame cannon imbues your
sword with fire
now the loaded axe sort of follows up
with a double bladed slash and the
shuriken arm
enables a really op dash attack after
you
distract them with the projectile and we
already know that we'll be able to
unlock more prosthetics but i think it's
possible that they might go even further
and allow you to customize what the
combo attack of each prosthetic weapon
might be
it's not confirmed but i could
definitely see it happening
and everyone's been asking how are they
going to fit in the moonlight greatsword
and i reckon if it's gonna fit anywhere
it's probably gonna fit
onto that prosthetic arm in some way but
currently though what you see
is what you get and honestly even these
weapons
already had some applications that i
didn't know about
after hours of experimenting so one of
my questions
to the activision and from software
folks was what their prosthetic weapon
of choice
was and they gave me some really
passionate answers
so while yasuhiro booted up sakiro to
show me his play style
robert conkey went into good depth on
why the shuriken arm was so good
and he explained that first up it could
be used in mid-air
and still allow you to dash when you
land he also said that
it's able to actually interrupt
opponents out of dangerous stances
and can also sometimes interrupt the mid
attack which is cool
and he also pointed out that it's just
great for combat against multiple
enemies because you can sort of
pick out enemies from the crowd really
easily
and it was around this time that
yasuhiro showed off how good he was with
the loaded axe revealing that it offers
a good amount of hyper armor
which means you can't be interrupted
while you're using it it has a repeating
attack
which i don't have footage of
unfortunately and also
that it has a mid-air attack that comes
out
a lot faster than its regular grounded
attack
so those two are really good but
personally
i'm still a sucker for anything that can
set my weapon on fire
but i'm starting to see how much depth
there could be for prosthetic weapons in
the future
and that includes the grappling hook of
course which
could also easily have its utility
its speed and its range improved for
example
and you guys remember the bushi from the
previous trailer he's the guy that gave
us
our prosthetic arm and i'm willing to
bet that he will be the craftsman
that upgrades it right i honestly
wouldn't be surprised if his temple
served as the hub world in sikiro
actually
so his name in english is probably going
to be the sculptor
because we find his idols all over the
demo
statues that translate roughly from
japanese to
demon buddha they serve as sekiro's
bonfire system
which leads me to believe that these
idols
or whatever god or being they represent
might be what's keeping us from death's
door and considering there are
checkpoints
in sequituro it's a good thing that he
carved so many
and while we're here i do have to show
you this uh as i was about to sit down
at one of these idols
i got ambushed by a spearman and as he
went to stab me
it missed i didn't get hit and i was
confused at the time
i thought it was a glitch but when i
gave it a closer look i realized that
the spear actually missed my shoulder by
a hair
by a pixel and isn't that insane the
hitboxes in these games are getting
really really tight and considering all
the acrobatics that sikiro does
like sliding and jumping and dodging
i can't wait to see how else we can
dodge attacks
imagine how many style points you will
get for
sliding under a sword or a spear or
something
that would look amazing you do get a few
start points
for rolling over downed enemies now
which looks cool
but i can't for the life of me figure
out why you would dodge over an enemy
like this
instead of just executing them not quite
sure yet
but the sheer amount of execution styles
in securo so far is fantastic
there are back executions there are
frontal executions
diving executions jumping executions
which i don't have that much footage of
and probably more honestly as it stands
posture
is at the absolute core of all gameplay
in sikiro more than health in many cases
so understanding exactly
how it works is key this is the
educational part of the video
so to start if your posture gets maxed
out
then you will be knocked flat on the
ground and you'll be vulnerable until
you break roll back onto your feet so if
you max out their posture
then instead they get opened up to a
death blow which
kills them instantly so for your enemies
maintaining posture is everything since
losing it means instant death for them
but if you lose your posture it only
really is a mild inconvenience for you
on the flip side though health is the
most important thing for your character
and for them health isn't that important
but we'll explain health in a second so
posture
actually recovers over time and it
recovers particularly when
the characters aren't doing anything
when they're not blocking an attack when
they're not attacking or when they're
not dodging
so offensive play is actually really
encouraged
because you don't want your enemy to get
their posture back
however the speed at which posture comes
back
is actually tied to health so if an
enemy is
low on health then you can take your
time with them you can
toy with them because there's no real
risk of them recovering their posture
at that point so after you've been
offensive and you've dealt a bit of
damage
you don't have to be quite as offensive
if that makes sense
and the same goes for you and there are
other ways to get your posture back
you can heal you can perform a counter
you can execute someone or if you're
this guy
you can use this special posture
recovery move
so we've just explained the consequences
of losing your posture
and the consequences of losing your
health now
let's get into the actual combat which i
think it might be my favorite combat
system
because it's this beautiful complex
dance of
offense and defense and it feels so good
and it feels so complex
and that's the reason this part of the
video is kinda boring to explain because
i could talk for a really really long
time about all of this
so let's break it down if you attack an
enemy
your opponent is forced to a take damage
or b block and interestingly
even if they block the attack perfectly
enemies will
lose posture no matter what so there is
currently
no reason for you not to attack because
you're guaranteed to at least damage
their posture
and you could damage their health as
well if you're lucky and before we
explained the benefits of lowering your
enemy's health
but health works a bit differently for
mid bosses than it does for regular
enemies
if a smaller enemy loses all their
health they will die
but if a mid boss loses all their health
they actually won't die and you'll have
to work down their posture bar
to actually execute them which will
happen a lot more easily because
they're low on health and they won't be
able to regenerate their posture
so you might be wondering attacking
enemies sounds
really opie because they're always
guaranteed to at least
lose health or posture but the thing is
tougher enemies will actually eventually
dodge those attacks
or they'll acquire hyper armor and mount
their own assault
that just brute forces through your own
attacks look at this
so this will force you to either take
damage or block
and now you're on the defensive but
luckily for you
a good defense can totally undo an
opponent's offense
so you hold down l1 to block and
you're rewarded for timing your blocks
perfectly
in game this is called a deflect but
you're probably more used to them being
called
parries if you block an attack late your
blade will make
a dull sound like this and while you
won't take damage
your posture meter will increase but if
you block an attack
perfectly your blade will make this high
pitch sound
and you'll take no damage you'll take no
posture damage
and you'll also inflict posture damage
to your opponent so if you keep up a
really perfect
defense you'll eventually create an
opening for a death blow
now we haven't even mentioned dodging or
anything like that
so you want to dodge when you see this
symbol pop
up this means danger in japanese
and these attacks are impossible to
block actually i shouldn't say that i
think
they're very difficult to block there
were moments in the demo where i did
block them but
i'm pretty sure it's very rare and very
difficult anyway the point of the danger
symbol
is actually that you shouldn't try to
block this and that it's much better to
try something else so if the attack is
slow then you can just interrupt it with
your own attack
and if the attack is a low sweep then
you can just jump over it
and if the attack is a thrust or
something that you think you can just
move out of the way of then you should
dash dash
is a faster version of jump but it only
gives you
horizontal spacing it doesn't put you up
in the air at all
and there's a fourth option that you
might not know about because it's pretty
rare to see in the demo
but if you're very confident that the
warning attack
is a thrust attack then you can go full
anime
and perform makiri this makiti counter
where you stamp on your enemies attack
negates the attack
it restores your posture and it can even
open your opponent
up to a death blow which makes it
probably the highest skill cap
thing you can do in sikiro i think
because
it's pretty dangerous to dodge into an
attack especially if you're not sure
if it's a thrust and even more
interestingly
in our interview yasuhiro mentioned that
makidi was an unlockable skill
which leads me to believe that there
might actually be other types of counter
available which is really cool
i actually see a lot of people
criticizing the idea of a warning attack
because they think it's hand-holding or
they think it's going to make the game
more accessible
but they're wrong because warning
attacks aren't just telling you to do
one thing they're not just saying hey an
attack is coming
you need to dodge they're actually
telling you hey there's a dangerous
attack coming
and you need to decide whether you're
going to counter-attack
counter with mckitty dash or jump
and that's entirely up to your reflexes
and having the warning symbol show up at
all
actually enables your reflexes to act
even faster
and helps with decision making and i
know not everyone defines combat in this
way but
i would define good combat as enabling
the player to
make multiple effective decisions over a
short period of time
and the warning symbol system actually
tells you that there's a complex
decision to be made
not the opposite and it actually enables
the complex combat of sikiro to flow
so fast the best example of good combat
in the demo
is the samurai general who you're
probably getting pretty sick of seeing
by this point he has it all though he
has two health bars he has
insane attack variety he has hyper armor
attacks he has
charged attacks numerous warning
abilities
and he's even got this special move that
replenishes all his posture which might
actually be an unlockable skill for our
character hopefully
the samurai general like the chained
ogre is
a mid-boss a sort of mini boss that from
software says that we can expect to see
more of
in sikhiro and in their level design and
i really liked it because the ogre and
the samurai general and
the other secret hidden enemy i'm not
allowed to talk about
they made the levels like really
memorable and i think it's way more
memorable than fighting a bunch of
smaller enemies
another thing that made the levels
really memorable was the music
so one of the best things about souls i
always thought
was how melancholy and quiet
the overworld is i actually love the
ambient noise in souls games
so at first i was kind of skeptical of
sakiro
because there's this mid-level music
but i have to say it's grown on me when
you're out of combat
the music is quiet and brooding but
as soon as combat begins it's drums
wind flutes and vocals all beating to
the sound of swords clashing
and blood spraying it suits sakiro's
faster combat
and in addition to that it actually
serves a bit of a purpose because
when you're sneaking around it's really
quiet but then as soon as you get
spotted
the action music kicks in and it breaks
the tension
and the calm of stealth in terms of
criticism
there really isn't too much i can say
because it's all subject to change
but here is my feedback so far so first
the ui now from software's uis in demos
always change and i think it's fair to
say that this one has to change a little
bit too
i found it a little bit strange that
health is off to the left
for our character and for enemies
especially since
health is actually linked to posture so
in my opinion it would make a bit more
sense if
health and posture were linked and
represented in the middle of the screen
or something like that although i'm not
a ui expert
i want to say that healing was really
annoying in the demo because it's bound
to
up on the d-pad with item use and up on
the d-pad is a really annoying button to
press while you're trying to move
with the left thumb stick it's a bit
easier on a ps4 controller but it's
quite difficult on an xbox controller i
found
but sikiro has a ton of new inputs
there's
jump there's eavesdrop you have to cycle
through your prosthetic weapons
so it's not really a surprise that they
had to put healing
on the d-pad but we'll see how that goes
um third when you fall off a cliff
insecure you actually don't die you
don't even
necessarily lose a life you actually
just take damage
from falling off a cliff and i don't
think i'm a fan of that
it's already pretty difficult to fall
off cliffs in sikiro
because your character actually just
sticks to the edge of platforms he
doesn't just fall off
so it's hard to fall off and i think you
should actually
lose a life if you fall off because that
way
there's less teleportation there's more
tension and
when you jump off the bridge during the
boss fight which happened to me twice
you should still get a second chance i
think just losing health is a little bit
too
generous the difficulty is on point
though
don't you worry about that if you think
it's too easy
that's because i'm biased and i'm
probably not showing you
all the times that i played really badly
and to be honest
you haven't seen the rest of the demo
the boss is hard the optional enemy in
the demo
is really hard and i only beat
both of these enemies once and that was
because i had hours
with the game only a few people defeated
the boss at gamescom
and i only heard of one other person who
defeated
the headless enemy and i asked around a
fair bit
so yeah it's fair it's full of secrets
and
the game is tough as nails so don't
worry
but again if you ever find a convention
that has this demo
available go there line up play it
because can you tell i adore this game i
really do
like you guys know that i get excited
for every new from software game
and that i am biased and it is my job
and everything right but
honestly sakiro is a little bit
different than usual because
every souls game evolves every souls
game adds new
things right but sequito is the first
from software game that i've played that
is actually
replacing things it's actually cutting
parts out of the salt's formula
that people love they're taking risks
and
they're making a lot of plebs upset and
basically
they're cutting off a perfectly
functional arm and they're replacing it
with
something they think is even better see
if you can spot the metaphor
uh it's risky it's new but whatever
they're doing
it is working 100 it is absolutely
working and
i think that's part of the biggest
reason why this feels like the biggest
evolution of souls combat to date
you're gonna have to excuse my gushing
for a little bit longer
it was actually really cool to be at
gamescom because i got to hear from a
couple of folks at activision who had
never really played
a souls game before and you could tell
they were starting to figure out
why from software's games are so special
and i love that
helping people see why from software's
games are so great
is literally at the core of why i even
make
videos right so i got such a kick out of
going to gamescom
and seeing that joy anyway that's enough
of sikiro
until tokyo game show most likely uh
i'll be making videos of that as soon as
i can so subscribe
if you're interested in finally seeing
the monk boss
and if you're a patron i'll be uploading
the raw uncompressed footage
for you guys whether it's gamescom or
tokyo game show in a month or so
that's as a reward for supporting the
channel so thank you very much
and until next time guys i'll see you
later